[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the goblet of fire
alba dumbledore barty crouch jr and
alistair
mad i moody more specifically i'm going
to be addressing the question
of whether or not dumbledore realized
that moody was indeed a fake
when the 94 school year began like with
any other year
all of the students gathered the great
hall at the beginning of term
this was an opportunity for dumbledore
and any professors
to address the student body the
beginning of the year announcing
anything pertaining to the upcoming
school year
1994 was the year that once again a new
defense against the dark arts teacher
took over famed death eater captor
alistair
madai moody despite his outwardly
striking and
intimidating appearance moody was one of
the good guys
he was in the business of capturing dark
wizards and business was booming
the prospect of having alistair moody
teaching defense against the dark arts
was exciting i mean he was an expert
after all
but at the same time there was something
odd about moody
from the moment he first enters the
great hall students are transfixed by
him
a man stood in the doorway leaning upon
a long staff
shrouded in a black travelling cloak
every head in the great hall swiveled
towards the stranger
suddenly brightly illuminated by a fork
of lightning that flashed across the
ceiling
he lowered his hood shook out a long
mane of grizzled
dark gray hair then began to walk up
towards the teacher's table
a dull clunk echoed through the hall on
his every other step
he reached the end of the top table
turned right
and limped heavily towards dumbledore
another flash of lightning crossed the
ceiling
hermione gasped the lightning had thrown
the man's face
into sharp relief and it was a face
unlike any
harry had ever seen it looked as though
it had been carved out of weathered wood
by someone who had only the vaguest idea
of what human faces were supposed to
look like
and was none too skilled with a chisel
every inch of skin
seemed to be scarred the mouth looked
like a diagonal gash
and a large chunk of the nose was
missing but it was the man's eyes that
made him frightening
he stretched out a hand that was as
badly scarred as his face
and dumbledore shook it muttering words
harry couldn't hear
may i introduce our new defense against
the dark arts teacher
said dumbledore brightly into the
silence professor moody
it was usual for new staff members to be
greeted with applause
but none of the staff or students
clapped except
dumbledore and hagrid both put their
hands together and applauded
but the sound echoed dismally into the
silence
and they stopped fairly quickly everyone
else seemed
too transfixed by moody's bizarre
appearance to do more than stare at him
alistair madai moody was a scottish
pureblood wizard born
into the moody family a family known for
producing a plethora
of amazingly talented auras in his youth
he attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry and later on in
his life and career
true to his family name went on to
become one of the most famous
and respected auras of all time auras
are of course members of an elite and
highly trained unit
of magical law enforcement they work for
the department of magical law
enforcement in the ministry of magic
and are trained to investigate dark
crimes
and detain dark witches and wizards his
reputation
certainly preceded him which is perhaps
one of the reasons that students and
professors alike
gawked at him another reason was his
physical appearance
human but hardly resembling one however
what no one knew at the time was that
this wasn't even the real moody
you see moody was always meant to teach
at hogwarts that year
but before term started he was captured
by bharti crouch jr
a british pureblood wizard and the son
of ministry of magic official
martinious crouch senior crouch jr
joined the death eaters in his teens and
was an impressive wizard in his own
right
being the first wizard ever to escape
from azkaban prison
in its 300 year history before term
started
crouch junior trapped moody in his own
magical trunk
and it wasn't until the fake moody was
ousted that he was released
interestingly enough crouch jr did not
only impersonate moody
via apologies potion but successfully
managed to teach
as defense against the dark arts
professor for most of the school year
legitimately acting in the role of
teacher the only real giveaways that
could have revealed that it wasn't the
real moody
were some questionable lessons
surrounding the unforgivable curses
but then again even the real moody was
an oddball
and no one would have put it past him i
wonder if being a
fake moody attracted additional
attention at the start of the year
or if moody would have had that general
effect on people anyway
anyway on to the important stuff did
dumbledore
ever wise and seemingly omniscient
somehow overlooked the fact that moody
was an impostor dumbledore is extremely
intelligent
which is why i've often questioned
whether or not he knew
something that we didn't when everyone
else is lost
dumbledore seems to always have an
answer so how could he have messed this
up
not only that but the real moody is
supposed to be a good friend of
dumbledore
so surely he would have recognized the
differences
in his friend's behavior right in order
to assume the form of moody
crouch jr used a polyjuice potion which
as we know
is limited to changing only physical
appearance
the polyjuice potion which is a complex
and time-consuming concoction
is best left to highly skilled witches
and wizards
it enables the consumer to assume the
physical appearance
of another person as long as they have
first procured
part of that individual's body to add to
the brew
this may be anything toenail clippings
dandruff
or worse but it is most usual to use
hair
so how was barty crouch jr able to so
convincingly behave
just like moody he seemingly fooled one
of the greatest wizards of all time
as much as i hate to say it i genuinely
don't think that dumbledore knew
that he was an impostor maybe dumbledore
is just getting old
or maybe he wasn't paying much attention
but he certainly didn't know
and if he did know then it would have
been massively irresponsible for him
to let crouch junior run free causing
all sorts of chaos in his wake
if he knew he could have prevented
things like the death of cedric diggory
not only that but he probably would have
wanted to have saved the real moody
his good friend here's why i think
dumbledore overlooked everything
first of all dumbledore hadn't seen
moody for a very long time
and we know this because he's described
as an old friend of dumbledore's
even if you're extremely close with
someone not seeing them for years
can cause you to forget their little
mannerisms and subtle behaviors
by the time dumbledore saw moody again
he probably either
a forgot about a lot of these subtle
behaviors
or b assumed he changed after all
moody is described as someone who
doesn't trust anyone anymore
which almost suggests he's a bit loopy
the mood you were introduced to in the
hogwarts banquet hall
is certainly unorthodox and dumbledore
may have just assumed
that it was the way that he had become
there are also a few other things to
consider
bharti crouch jr was an extremely
powerful wizard possibly one of the most
powerful death eaters
he captured moody after all this meant
that in addition to the polyjuice potion
he likely used additional spells and
enchantments
to further mask his real identity
effectively turning himself
into the closest possible thing to the
real alistair moody
not only that but crouch jr could have
accessed the real moody
in the chest at any point meaning that
he could have basically asked him
anything
i doubt that moody would be willing to
part with any information about himself
without a fight but i'm sure that crouch
jr is aware
of the necessary torture methods to get
information out of people
in short dumbledore didn't know he
hadn't seen moody for a long time
crouch junior did a great job at
impersonating him
and dumbledore also probably had a lot
of other stuff
on his mind and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time marvelous creatures dragons
aren't they
you